planned for the bombs
television journal of the important
things to look at all
partially eleven monday wednesday and
trust
presentation of the laundry
later on
launching the world's most ahmed walk
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
advancing
this is david rocks
may i introduce our co-editors
for this edition of the launching cross
school
mister william bradford hwy
and mister henry password
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable john sherman
cooper
senator-elect from kentucky
so the cooper
very happy to welcome you to costco this
evening
i'd like to begin by asking you because
of your experience in the u_n_
what do you think there's any chance for
a truce in korea now
because of the moment
immediately
uh... i i do not think so
fortran immediate troops and frankly i
have never felt that the
brushes
i think they're actually
in recent days
resolution and in a resolution is
for them and their forms
john mclaughlin says that he thinks he
has a clear a definite solution of the
problem
mistaken view of that that uh... general
eisenhower or consult with them now
forceps
question for general eisenhower
i have it i would guess that
he would be premature
to find out what his plan is
i think you'd been with me
or what steps do you think can be taken
to put their pressure on the chinese
communist of one approves
lois dot think of this
grand questions
this part of the
of the uh... larger
difficulties between russia and
the rest of the world
and with that
did you start out but knowing it
it's a difficult problem of a long
problem
because we have the
real force there
uh... i believe that
we've got
the strength in korea
which will give the greatest
influence to our
well a lot of some of us absolutely
suspects of the viewpoint
not knowing the sales but the
military dispositions are there
i'm not certain
how much should be added but
before the convention russia
measure primarily that
that they cannot win that they must
adjust the position of
and graham and i think we've got to have
the straight brother
uh... certainly favor the
the proposition in general eisenhower
that his quickly as we can
we build up the streets of south korea
very strongly that
every bit of influence that we can bring
to bear upon
the other members of the united nations
should be brought
to get from them
military strength added economic
strength lozano thank god for our
yours of course the night of thinking
about the
u_s_s_
helen out in the pacific and all of this
uh... meetings going on out there
uh... nasa first of all
uh... why do you think all of these
cabinet members of the most out to sea
general eisenhower and carried aboard
the that helicopter
with mrs
it's a good operation
well you know the illusion that had a
little melodramatic fiorello no i don't
think so i think spare parts
the the first place
everybody
presented in korea
he's he's just finished up whatever
information that he could get their and
i think it's
with his
experience it
that he has got
new information and
much clearer beautiful
mister those has been in washington
conferring with the state before
me has there been
and now they meet together and
there's a chance to
bring together
those with different viewpoints
but we'll be right back
i think that probably the best
opportunity he'll have
until the takes the oath of office
and perhaps for a long time after that
as many of his advisers together and
have the chance
attitude confer without interruption
well is it wrong about other things
besides career that
right here on wednesday
one of the things that make you
intersting bad years and here is
uh... you republican who's just uh...
been elected to the senate down in
kentucky
and i believe that you are the only
republican
that was elected to the senate
an estate
it did not vote for eisenhower
is that correct sir
but that is true but
it just like a few votes of voting for
as a narrative
about a million votes
mister stevenson shed kentucky of only
seven hundred votes and yet uh... no
stevenson kid to state you were elected
to the senate
that bat what what was your majority
twenty nine thousand
now add let me ask you this year
plan where you elected to the senate
uh... what did you have the general
eisenhower didn't have been that in
kentucky
i'd like to make it for him
i thought it would be here on this
program
it's at all as a diabetic cannon
so that they want why do you think he
has
it made the change
but why do you think you're an admitted
ticket into packages
is because you
there well no no no i haven't said much
the third race are made for the senate
and six years
and of course
they do normally
i would hope so
i was on the senate two years and
and uh... they approved of my records
there
you are and i was on the ground notified
all the time generalize matter came into
kentucky one day
we're getting money back to you the care
kentucky
the floor of about eight or nine months
i was on the ground every day making
fight one dollar out of the republican
party is a strong in kentucky and these
are the growing party there
los angeles
unquestionable always ask as and you are
a republican from kentucky
actually
this kentucky has a rather strong
republican party out of about
million registered voters
we have a registered voter about two
hundred and twenty five
thousand registered republicans
weekends too
consistent with the republican vote
since nineteen hundred we've had five
out of the fifteen governors
which are about the first republican has
been sent to congress
live from top team twenty five years
when she won nineteen forty six the
ninety minutes or so if there was a
first
one we've been elected the senate
for the senate and twenty five years
sultana khobor really huge insurance
from a state that has a strong
republican party what do you think of
the republican party's chances
making the south the reluctant party
system itself
my status
said a border state
and and and then that uh... kevin
or you could class west virginia
missouri
even tennessee
i think that
all of those states those four states
have
to become republican states are
to at least two
then a position where they could
republican majorities
a much more often
and i think there that's a problem
reminders from outside from the
in kentucky
and these border states
parties in those states watching their
leadership
having good programs and uh...
in my best to develop their own party i
think the situation in the south is
different
at lower higher status not typically
southern state politically
rests on the same problems
where the problem of
not having local and state
administrations which give your
continuity
where we can beat themselves is too
take advantage of the azamara pickford
to take into the leadership
some of the democrats who
for generalizing undertaken that
leadership even more
informing
young people
came under his banners here's a national
holiday although you're
republican you have been
serving as a delegate on the u_n_
happens to under the as an appointee of
the truman administrators are served as
a governor in nineteen forty nine and
because of your experience there i'd
like to ask you some questions about the
u_n_ phrase do you think the in the
united nations is says
wealth has been it's not a success in
the terms of
people have hoped
i think it's had a successful
i think it's great successes of his
it's been a national astronaut which
as hell together
the nation's where members of the
satellite nations and russia
and kept them pretty generally reform
fence posts as against rs russian
domination and aggression or has as one
of those things affect being to act as a
sounding board for rashi in propaganda
against the united states
has just given a rash of
a forum
is also given united states
smaller countries whistle
it was given
or the other nations of the world there
at least the representatives of their
chance to
uh... see the russians to hear them and
our allies their propaganda i think
that's been a definite valley
grocer our viewers i'm sure would like
to have
reviews on about the republican party is
likely to do on domestic issues
on january the twentieth
first of all so you believe that the
republican party will reduce taxes
i think the loop
take the steps which will lead to
revenge from texas
i think production taxes depends of
walpole would happen soon
general
were so you think that the uh... that
the republican party will attempt to
repeal any of the so-called social
legislation
that's been built up by the new unfair
deals
detail
there may be
specific laws will be repealed
in general
i think the general programs of social
security
weijin are lol
some labor legislation
well i don't know if your program and
will be maintained but they will be
examined and analyzed
when you come from the state business
they'd consider believable
you think that they'll be more strikes
i have the believes that there will be
fewer strokes
i think we'll all have already seen some
evidence of that sense
election subscribe to bring some reason
i say that is
i believe that one
labels
and capital as well but
i think particularly labor because
understood
evaluate
i think a stronger advocate but
and the merits always
when they know now that they've got to
do what they say they want to do bargain
collectively
well then you're going to have better
chances for green rockwell
and clarence and tanya seven thank you
for being with us thank you very much
the opinions you heard our speakers
expressed tonight are entirely the wrong
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promised go forth mister
william bradford here really
and mister henry has lived
our distinguished guests was their
honorable john sherman cooper
senator-elect from kentucky
under any christmas tree yes the little
packages which intrigue
what can it be we say
and this christmas many hope that the in
one like this there'll be a long gene
the world's most alright watch
throughout the world no other name on a
christmas watch means so much as the
name along gene
and the whole world there were a few
watches two week we're launching and
quality and none of such great grandma
among the finest waters of the world
launching alone is one ten world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medal
awards and so many honors for accuracy
now if this christmas you wish to give
the gift of great prestige
along gene
every mon gene watches superlative and
styling superb in finnish
unsurpassed for fateful timekeeping
the unbelievably you made by and
probably give alone gene watch this
christmas for as little as seventy one
fifty
launching the world's most all earth
watch
the world's most on a christmas gift
printing up product
along gene whitmore what's company since
eighteen sixty six
maker of what is the behind us karen
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
for the long gene krupa school a
television journals of important issues
of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most are not watch
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on a launching
this is david ross speaking for your
regular host prime night reminding you
of the long g_-men whitmore watchers are
sold in service from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading to
proudly display this emblem
agency for launching britain all walked
killers that i've spent
the dole along artwork locke walked off
aqui honking
plunging watchers have one can wear a
program prices twenty eight gold medals
and more honors for accuracy than any
other countries
well into the world's most honored
watches maidan guaranteed but i want to
work more watch company
meantime mother launching monitored
television journalist william clark
intentionally out
talk show you every monday wednesday and
friday
the presentation of the launching what
are what count
later on
long jane the world's most ahmed watch
and what
you know a distinguished companion to
the world on and on gene
good evening this is frank night
named reduce our quoted to us for this
edition of the long-chain promise co
first of all die roger as a matter of
the new york harold red beyond and
mister william bradford keighley
edit where all the american market
our distinguished guests for this
evening is they are over air flight one
o_
united state senator from oklahoma
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
german army at
house will vote against
remembered you sir as
very energetic
freshman senator who want to read a
dramatic victory in oklahoma last year
ten first i think they'd like to locate
you in the political climate
i believe you're a democrat actors and
you have a fury and uh...
and you call yourself a favor
i wouldn't hardly call myself a regular
i call myself a bit darker arrival girl
with the democrats uh...
generally but
time again i
call as i say hammond sometimes i can't
go wrong and general however you are
supported administration journal yes i
think we're on the right policy to help
this country
find prosperity and peace
well i'm sure that our guest would like
to have your reactions on the corruption
issues
now are you concerned over d corruption
stories that are breaking daily in the
press
him i think it's one of the greatest
problems this country faces his team
continue to be give a patient honest
government and we cannot tolerate
anything less think the important thing
about
the corruption that has been uncovered
it has been uncovered by a democratic
congress
in both houses and that the committees
that have been investigating of benjamin
button
unep
you're not sleeping under under the rug
do you think it's a problem of the
country or a problem of the
administration
i think it's problem a bull i think
you're always going to have a certain
percentage of man of bad faith one now
you have uh...
a large sums of money
camel in large problems panel important
thing is to prosecute those to the
fullest extent of your body
and to be sure that and he uh...
dereliction of duty is thoroughly
cleaned up
if you're the president as
round prone to sidestepped the issue
uh... i don't really has i think he is
he's moved in just a strong as he can on
this uh...
corruption i think the changes that have
been made and will be made will prove
that uh... we're going to bring us up
this disbanded early as it can be done
they in fact i have said that
did the situated in reflect some uh...
laxity in the white house itself
uh... i couldn't say that there have
been mistakes in apartments perhaps and
then uh... i think the system probably
wrong i think one of the things that
happen
that concerns me most is that the uh...
things are coming out about the internal
revenue depart
and i believe that the political
appointments
is the wrong system to trust you
political henchman the collection of
sixty billions of dollars i think i'll
be career work now either
so fair some introduction of illinois
state on the show not long ago
he thought that uh...
that was some they call it collapse of
conscience in the country or that the
company was losing some of its capacity
from our own indignation
how are your views on that last well sir
i can certainly senator here in the
country properly and they get the
congress and properly indignant and the
fact that the important thing
about this corruption issue is that it
is being cleaned out and will be cleaned
up at the country was tolerating it
the country just rub their children
several is followed by the some of this
and what can you do about it
that would be something to worry about
the fact is your cock to get it and
you're out to clean about who feel that
this will have something
tacked on the forthcoming elections
undoubtedly it will be a part of uh...
the campaign to be one of the things
democrats will probably be called to
account for work through their document
uh... unless the things properly cleaned
up and i believe it will be properly
cleaned up and the guilty people
punished and on the system it is wrong
and by that i mean the system used by
both parties that's political
appointments for
internal revenue positions
chevy chase's civil service and career
point
now speaking of the next election sir
i believe that you have just been uh...
had something to do with the
investigation into how the actions of
the amount of money spent in the
re-election of senator pat yet i trust
you dollar what conclusion did you
reached afternoon investigating that
election well this is not the first
though i think we've been handling
investigated several states uh... malino
harlan several others
we've got the conclusion that we've got
tighten up the loopholes in the corrupt
practices act was passed in nineteen
hundred twenty-five and the
limits that uh... fixed ten thousand
dollars per state of new yorker for the
state of california these tremendous
aloha
is entirely unrealistic in the lab
today's demands and
you're always going to have money spent
in excess of those amounts unless you
correct the loopholes and put the
realistic lemony and make the cabin
accountable for every dime is spent on
his behalf whether by satellite
organization over by the calving time
you didn't investigate or how they
deliver effort to discredit senator ted
i think i think senator kapiti u_n_ will
say it was a very poor investigation
factor
we got more complaints from the ferguson
side regarding investigated brookside
darania article about all would you go
about
uh... amending the corrupt practices act
eliminate
uh... so much money being spent during
an election
well i think in the first place you
ought to put a realistic limit on what
can be spent to say ten thousand dollars
to one of the senate seat in ohio
is entirely fantastic he didn't have
television radio
in have colored prelinger billboards
read things in nineteen hundred and
twenty-five murder mandatory to be used
in a
campaigning today
crazy anyone raising any probably two
hundred and fifty thousand i have a
million dollars
if necessary in these big states and
then requirements and accounting
but every time i spent
whether by the camera that format
the satellite organizations
that now spend money on his behalf
ostensibly without the camera knowing is
being spent
now let's relate your conclusions do
the probabilities of nineteen fifty two
zip
do you anticipate uh... paid very
vigorous campaign and fifty-two or i
think it'd be one of the barest and
perhaps one of the dirtiest political
campaigns history unless the congress
passes a new set of mark is approved by
the rules we don't have to have some
some pattern with which both parties can
live by in a bizarre do you think they
made a uh... we may set a record and
national expenditures unless something
is taken out and i think it would be
easily possible if you consider i think
uh... million two hundred thousand being
spent in uh... uh... the path campaign
and by his supporters for other portions
of the republican ticket and perhaps a
eight hundred thousand for the
democratic side you can do
thirty fantastic sums for one of the
forty eight states but we also set a
national record of mud-slinging
well i think that's liable to be one of
the dangers and we're trying to work on
mister levin and uh...
defamatory statements i think that is
another danger that you can tear
up-to-date fabric of government played
on a limited insight fighting
that major well we're trying to do it
and senate races by a giving notice now
on the senate rules
that uh... a man's campaign the type of
campaign that he runs will be uh... one
of the matters in which he's just freeze
qualifications to be
a member of the united states senate
senator your promenade
and border states
so our audience tonight would be very
much and it did in your predictions for
nineteen fifty two
now specifically do you think the
president will be a candidate to succeed
himself but you know i don't believe you
well that's only a guess no one has ever
told me that uh... observed political
swing voters that political writer and
i'll either as a congressman about the
standards then
we do you think will be democratic
nominee of course my guess is that uh...
speaker sam rayburn will be the logical
man to be the democratic why do you
think sam rayburn
well in the first place he's held the
number two job in this country which is
bigger than it is far more important the
vice presidency longer than any benefit
uh... any manner his never served in the
house of representatives is order sam
rayburn zend you've got uh...
hunters out throughout the country and
all forty eight states who believe any
men respect
what about his political location
at the democrats have nominated a
southerner for president many years
that's right but uh... sam fortunately
have demonstrated over the years that
he's been speaker the house of complete
parents for both the northern mister
then you can ask any man from new yorker
connecticut massachusetts certainly the
northern states is never served in the
house with rayburn
and you'll find that they are saying all
times of mister abrams an extremely fair
now as to political settlement in your
state
if the election were held today sir andy
race were between uh... mister rayburn
and senator taft
how do you think oklahoma go well i
really believe oklahoma would vote for
mister reagan and out
suppose a referee between
uh... mister rayburn and mister
eisenhower general idea
my stride and i would make a very very
uh...
hard candidate to beat the only way you
could begin perhaps would be to uh...
connect him up with the republican
congress that he'd have to work with
during the uh... the four years if you
were elected
and rodney republican congressional
record
do you think that uh...
general eisenhower will be a candidate
well courses bento off a lot of
congressmen and senators and
others trying to find out the answer
that question month yes is that he will
not be a camp i'd like to have one uh...
uh... their observation from you sir
senator smathers and young man itself is
on the radar in front of the night
and we were talking about what days
young congressman
are you
hopeful this year about what's going to
happen in this country sir
off because i feel a lot better about
this uh... leslie
finish this year than i did stock
volume we're beginning to see our way
through this uh...
colon
partially heartwarming right nineteen
fifty two will be a europe war economy
and a half packed
that's all india twelve it will still
have our restrictions on building and
priorities and think that there are no i
don't believe you can get taxes and
happily been briefed about the point of
diminishing removals will develop
uh... yes table the senate as i
understand that you've said in the night
you are
quite concerned about the corruption
issue
you are interested and uh...
putting a ceiling on expenditures
and you think that we're going to have a
very high
presidential race in nineteen fifty two
thank you very much for coming up martin
and being with us
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching probable cause
mr dot i rogers
and mister william bradford puri
our distinguished guests was the
honorable layouts like my money
united states and other from oklahoma
now here
is that correct
can be a good lesson on an important
subject
how to buy a christmas gift for
just look at this lodged
long gene watched move
it's a beauty
i hope you will not be sure
that it's a truly find mechanism
now there is a wage of judge anyone
and wounding told you about that in this
magazine advertisement which you may
have seen
area of the inference from them
gary isn't too thin line
now you can with judge anyone
client threat of honors and
accomplishments throughout the world
and here is a long jean-michel
at world's fair as an international
exposition
launching watches f_-one highest honors
in every single competition they've
answered
the total ten worlds better grand prizes
and twenty eight gold medals
inaccuracy competitions
at the national observatories
the record of launching watches these
equally extraordinary
since eighteen seventy eight
prize after prize
and right now the record for wristwatch
accuracy at notre dame observatory is
held by long g
and so it goes in every field of precise
timing are unique record of laundry on
as an achievement all over the world
now what does this record through
it proves one thing very conclusively
throughout the world no other name on a
christmas gift watch
means so much as long journey
the world's most on it well
and if you pay seventy one fifty or more
for a christmas watch you're paying the
price of a laundry
so why not insist on getting a long day
in the world's most honored watch
premium product of the laundry mcnaught
watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watchers are the highest
character
bitches ragtime began inviting you to
join us every monday wednesday and
friday at the same time par
along came from
a television journal of the important
issues of the odd
broadcast on the top of launching
the world's most all night long
what nala distinguished companion to the
world on it laundry
sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leaving going
to
will probably display of event
they've been played ball daunting what
norwalk
on the road off ho
plunging watchers have one can wear a
program prices twenty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other party
form to the world's most honored
watchers may ten guaranteed by the log
in what what what company
time for the lawn games on it
television journalist william carpenter
said nothing about
partial you every monday wednesday and
friday
the presentation of the laundry list
well what's happened
later on
laundry the world's most al-kidwa
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world
honored laundry
good evening with the fact that
mail and reduce our co-editor of further
status and all the laundry in
cartersville
but they were there were bradford
hearing at a pair of the american market
and bethlehem i have
editor of the freemen and contributing
editor for newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening if the elder brother fifty-four
united state senator from tennessee
the opinions expressed
not necessarily those of the speaker
syndicate roar of the members of our
promise to avoidance of course
remember your sir from here sensational
crime investigation
they know that your the vigorous
financially i do now
aspires to be a democratic nomination
for the presidency
denial again to appreciate
views on some of your political views
concert
if you are running for the democratic
nomination
what is your
criticism of what is your principal
criticism
obey democrat at democratic
administration that now exist
immature they're going to make it very
clear in the beginning that
firemen reading online
i'm not uh... i think that we have had a
inspiring democratic administrations
i have supported the foreign policy in
the economic and social
bubble president roosevelt infested p_m_
here anywhere in the editor well i don't
uh... i don't care for them as
threatened
on the dealers won't leave them out
and uh...
we're going to new dealer fairview
avenues with the american people have
made great advancement
both in our foreign policy and our
domestic policy on ruby
rescue democratic administration
you want to know why i'm running for
president
i feel that uh...
every american bar area
spires too
i want to do what i can do
see that we continue on with me
aggressive foreign policy
the do not abandoned their place of
leadership in the world
also i'm very much interested in seeing
as we continue to have our social
economic gains
i doing
market place additional emphasis upon
the necessity of taking affirmative
action
and made effort against uh... corruption
ones too
to federal government
taking more leading parts both congress
and the negative
department in the
leadership the mattress
living in the mail today or tomorrow i
feel that we must uh...
okay on the sound of fire financial
basis but we cannot go on year after
year on the basis of deficit
nothing to do it if there's room for
so you think almost certainly on the
program
uh... not as you know
but i think there is room for it
near arab leaders and uh...
number of people in both of our
political party
welfare i think the band that if there
are two red issues between you and me
president one of the news that you don't
feel that
there is the within the black think
dealing with the corruption territory
sufficiently adequate dealing with it
and that you are worried about the
spending program with the landlord of
april i'm not the intended to kill
anybody that uh...
previous them then i think both in
government and government
but i think in congress in the executive
department in math
in our country general
at all levels of government that we
ought to place more purposes upon them
effort against the
racketeering the wrongdoer
the force of course i have had a more
deferment
familiarity with uh...
the condition in the country today them
perhaps and other people so it doesn't
trust me as being something that we must
first take a
action
uh... all along the line and the federal
level of government at the moment
people who think that is we didn't need
to know i would think that i'm not
trying to break in the i'm not trying to
grow issues between
and truman announced for
than anyone else in moscow
running for senate
fear that i have the qualifications that
i've had the experience
that i have the ideas for the future of
america which
the american people want which will
appeal to the voters of america flips on
a day or if there are differences as you
formula
on basic philosophy though
you you are at an impasse sense our
people must make some choices in
nineteen fifty on basic philosophy you
approve
most of what was done domestically and
in foreign policy in the roosevelt
administration but also in the truman
administration i thought that mister
fuhrman as a political figure you want
to extend the philosophy album roosevelt
and truman administration
uh... generally that's true and i want
to see them carried on earth
vigorously i think i do have some
manner points of difference as to our
foreign policy
but i think that we have been growing
maintaining and carrying out our
position of leadership in the world
interest
you're not having a very uh... i think
that we did a
i think in the united nations and the
mid-atlantic
we have done things that were necessary
and you are not concerned with our are
being overextended abroad you believe
that we do have
commitments abroad and that we must
continue to
large sums of money abroad and we must
continue to pump station american troops
abroad
and be generally concerned uh... greatly
concerned with what goes on in the rest
of the world
uh... yes i do i think that we have to
sheriff part of the responsibility along
with the other nations in the north
atlantic
i think the remotes the
joined other free people in the interest
of
i think that we must build four days
system of collective security that's
going to reverse the trend toward the
twenty five years
there through the that uh...
as to how much we should
spent on military withdrawal economic
assistance
biography in fact it over it
long period of time enough to get into
an actual war
or left the condition gets
first-degree
or going to have to come down and even
our defense
spending so that we
will not be bankrupting ourselves
indirect armed services committee we
have seen a preview of ways
both the military spending abroad
and then uh... the timing of our armed
services
where are your committee forum on the
record and unjustly committee
yes well currently
if this plea research
dole basically
you feel that the country would be
better all in nineteen fifty two
electing another democratic
administration so that you could
continue to carry on what's been put in
motion by roosevelt and truman yet that
week that certain demands that fewer i
think that uh...
we should have another democratic
administration
for samples that i have a
argument but i think it's very vital to
the country that we do elected democrat
and then of course we do have a
philosophy i think the general
courses we've been going on
all right
in the public interest
i don't know um... first erection and
the way a foreign policy we feel we've
we had a republican administration
and i think the fact that the republican
party generally has
the economic and social james lee
resource development that we've had in
the country
although many of them
favored it but at the party of opposed
it
where the not speak well for the future
of those programs and a republican
administration for summer most of the
people who have touched their
candidacies say that you think
opposition within the democratic party
from tour ends
while the southern democrats are
supposed to think that you too much in
favor of the fair deal
and uh... some of the administration
democrats feel that you had uh...
uh... been picking through with that
listen more
on the question of corruption
tomorrow would like to comment on that
yet from thirty one mr hope that uh...
that's quite true i had to face
opposition from both
in the south both in the north
forward points out that i think it's
going to be very difficult for us to
have a president who will
me to exact formula of into section of
the country
and then i think that in the section
that expects that is
does not looking at it from a number of
people
uh... how i feel that my
position
is the
uh... one of those take into
consideration various parts of the
country
and uh...
that's what i'm going to present to the
people
namrata category i think they will
understand that they
no section of the country can have a man
just exactly like the one they want
what do you think the president first
there
uh... took his name out of the primaries
of new hampshire and then decided to
back in again you anything on that
well uh... mister i have not have enough
trouble keeping up with my own
difficulties without the trying to
jetstar speculate about somebody else's
though all i know is that
reading the paper that
mister mckenna carpet organizational
reasons that
president should go back to me
new hampshire primary
i think the idea being that
the political
organization bear might suffer if uh...
even allows named
remain on the
primary but i never talked me into the
netherlands
for the final questions then everything
for karate went on to something too
will be decided by the voters inlet
coming campaign
or you're talking about you know a lot
about the presidential campaign he are
you remind me carol
and i think the government the
issue
there's a lot of foreign policy or we're
going to go on and strengthen and better
our foreign policy and
follow through with our position of
leadership for reform turn back time
scared you know
go to some extent
sent back to isolation
i think that's on one side
but i think on the other side that
the uh...
american people are going to believe
that the democratic party can better be
the better trusted to carry out our
social economic
than the republican party
but i think on those two things would be
an issue of course uh...
the bigger issue in government at this
time is
but cleaning up in a crime and
corruption taking leadership in the
interest of
battle against the part of a crime that
are going to have a lot of some of the
people have been reminded parade route
for not talking about but i don't think
mister
the editorial board with it but there's
no going on here in collinsville
flows mister william bradford hilly and
mister henry have
our distinguished guests was the article
that these people united states and
other from tennessee
none of the i nor the camera can
determine i went out at the events in
the winter olympics at oslo
the winner is determined by the world on
earth to watch
laundry
flip-flop soap
for timing championship sports in all
three
saltwater
there is one reason
and one reason alone
that greater accuracy of launching
watches all altaf
examined the records of the accuracy
trials of the great government
observatories and you'll find proof of
that statement
that is why championship sports in all
fields throughout the world
lose long-chain the world's most all
that loss
for official timing
why national and international sports
and contest associations have named long
gained at the facial walk
among these are the american automobile
association
the american powerboat association
and the national aeronautics association
if the greater accuracy of laundry mobs
of all time
that has made long jane the first choice
with discriminating manned and went on
everywhere
so if you wish
to buy it
quality watch of all the world
out of the also or as a gift
new should cool
laundry
preemie our product of the long gene but
law watch company
long-chain official rock
olympic winter games of nineteen fifty
two
joined up every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time
for the long dream come true
a television journal of the important
this is avail
broadcast on the drop-off laundry
the world most on that one
and wet law distinguished companion for
the world all night long game
so then seven from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading
killer
proudly display their family
agency logon gene but norwalk
this is playing tonight speaking
television generosity impulses
partially eleven months
is wednesday and friday
presentation of the long blah blah
later on
lodging
the world's most on it locks
and west
distinguished companion to the world on
and on gene
but evenings
this is david rocks
may i introduce our co-editors for this
edition
of the logging promise toh
mister william back with you we editor
of the american maturity
and mister darman by rockets an editor
of the herald tribune
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable everett
united states senate up from illinois
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
sided that's another one of the leading
republican spokesman in congress and
also the presidential campaign
would like some of your current views
from washington
now i understand sir that you have just
recently introduced a bill to in the
senate which would limit the powers of
the wage stabilization boyd
and since they dub usb is tied so
directly with the steel situation
uh... we should tell us something about
or mister rogers you're quite correct as
a matter of fact there is pending in the
senate banking committee at the present
time
an amendment to the i'd offer to the
defense production acted springs out of
the steel controversy
in essence of course it would uh... give
statutory authority of the week
stabilization
which exist today as a matter of fact
only under executive authority an
executive order
and secondly it would send back issues
like union shop in representation
to the national labor relations board
for administration of the taft hartley
act as designed by congress in the first
instance you not feel that these belong
with the dub usb
that's quite correct diminished one
other very important aspect of this
amendment and that is
that the number of members on the board
or public members must exceed the
aggregate of industry and labor members
and the public members would be
confirmed by the senate why do you wanna
do you insist on the senator dirksen do
you feel it
uh... wage stabilization boorda as it is
presently constituted is slanted toward
labor
well as a matter of fact i sat through
most of the testimony including that of
governor arnold the prize administrator
mister roger putnam the
economic stabilization administrate or
and also uh... mr fein together
and then later on of course we had
charlie wilson
and i came to the conclusion from the
testimony that they were more interested
in labor peace and they were in the
principle that was involved and that you
got some other old like sentiment and
for that reason i want to see the public
members of the board confirmed by the
senate because then at least
we can be sure we are going to get
public members
or represent the public interest while
senate there now
at present the waves stabilisation bull
as eighteen members have sneaked that's
correct and six out of my from labor and
six out them supposedly from industry
and six adam supposedly represent the
public events right and none of them are
confirmed by the senate none whatsoever
and all are appointed by the president
and what you want to do
who has to make most of them public
members
that require that the senate approved
them so that you can examine the record
in possible basses
outside each one of those members as a
matter of fact mr here i would have no
objection to making them all public
members because
it is a larger public interest that is
involved here and then have all of them
confirmed by the sent as a matter of
fact uh... when mister i was on our show
a couple of weeks ago he said that it
was in the public interest
that he made his decision for the
president to seize the steel industry
well that could be a matter of opinion
of course and uh...
when it comes to my own view point with
respect to see here i think it was
illegal i think it was on justifiable
i think it was on warranted and that
there was no constitution excuse for it
what's when you think that if the uh...
wage stabilisation board had a
public membership
mr otto would have been able to reach
this conclusion
i doubt very much as a matter of fact in
if you had
review of public representation on the
board confirmed by the senate
which chances are that we wouldn't have
this controversy on the national
doorstep today now this decks an
amendment
death to change that to redefine the
powers of the debbie s b
uh...
what what chance do you think that has
to being adopted well i think it has a
fair chance of course i do know sort of
holding the committee little from time
to time
and it for any reason it fails and the
committee certainly it will be offered
on the senate floor
and i'm of the opinion of course because
of the controversy now
that he will commend itself through the
serious thinking of the members of the
senate
now the administration is opposed to all
very definitely so
uh... what grounds
well dickie of course the board is
presently constituted is uh... doing a
good job
and uh...
where perhaps they don't want to set up
to start with the present our is there
any evidence from from your constituency
that
wsd is doing a good job anon whatsoever
that i know him as a matter of fact the
course of the people back home don't
know too much about the operations
within the book
i head however a chance to read the
recommendations of the vote many times
i read the dissenting views of the labor
members in the industry members
and i'd come to the conclusion that
there was a little bias there
and so in the hope of the eliminating
them and also to make sure there'll be
no recurrence of this difficulty into
other industries like oil and rubber and
aluminum that involve the national
interest in the defense efforts i want
to see the board reconstituted in given
statutory authority and the fear that
that will happen that uh...
similar situation staying loyal bears a
striking the on the streets present time
well mister rogers is a matter of fact
the controversy or relating to our live
before a couple of panels in the way
destabilization board at the present
time rubber maybe their aluminum might
come on
and there might be a good many others
and we simply cannot afford it could
very logical e progress to the door step
of sixteen hundred pennsylvania avenue
greg exactly so
senator al audience of course is gravely
concerned in this trip
crisis and i'm sure that they would
appreciate a prediction from you
how do you think this uh...
constitutional crisis is going to be
resolved well mister jerry of course
uh... the u_s_ supreme court is not
always predictable as you know
and there have been so many sharp
five-to-four
a defense industries and by the supreme
court they might vary conceivably not
pass on the seizure issue at all
and simply go on the theory
that the stupidly taft hartley act which
was created through by congress
and which is after all a trustee of
congress
operated by the national labor relations
board
has a certain authority in certain
remedies that have not yet been exercise
resume may very simply say
until all around these have been
exercised
various location for them to pass on a
major i you know you're saying sir that
you don't anticipate and heard a
decision by the supreme court in this
mail not necessarily agree with us on
this very shortly as a matter of fact
because of the high public interest
would like to know what you one other
observation from you sir
do you think that feeds
anything that has happened to the
judiciary that the american people
should be concerned about
is the judiciary still an adequate
check-and-balance on executive power in
this country
well i i i don't like particularly the
breath on that question except to say
that i can find you a lot of people in
the country
who have their fingers crossed for
matlab and i beginning to wonder whether
a political note has intruded itself
into the judicial findings in the
country
well speaking of crossing their fingers
in the intrusion of political notes on
it
thorsen
uh... this afternoon
or late this afternoon they
factories are for the washington
announced that it was
drawing controls on installment five
an announcement which i'm sure have some
profound effect around the country
do you know this any political influence
in this uh... decision uh... it means
essentially that all last
holdout
on controls
over the purchasing over the vast
spending that when i'm in this country
following the korean incident
is now listed
well now there's a right if you'll bear
with me just a minute i'll give you what
i think is around a dancer
first of all i share the view that has
been expressed by a number of people in
washington and in the senate
led by means of control by means of
credit control
by means of taxis and by means of
reduced public spending we might have
kept this thing in balance without the
necessity for the kind of physical
controls
that we have today
now then
i beginning to think that this thing
softens up and i see a softening of
business in a good many sections of the
country
that the administration seems to be
interested in keeping this
fate prosperity as i call it going until
election day
and if you need authority for it
we'll look at the president's message
here
on the state of the union to the joint
session in which he said the domestic
economic issues and the international
matters cannot be separated
that's just another happy way of saying
that you can't separate the cushy jobs
from the corpses in other words you
would feel so that
uh... the administration is endeavoring
to maintain inflation and to maintain
what you call a fake prosperity and solo
number four
well when you see the administration
candidate and a candidate for the
presidency around the country
talking about the prosperity of the key
the democrats have brought to the
country obviously that's going to be one
of the key issues with him in the
campaign
and if they're going to utilize it in
cash in on it they've got to maintain it
and and maintain it you've got to do
certain rather peculiar inquiries things
and maybe this is one of them
passive what do you mean bad faith
prosperity it what you call it a fake
prosperity well mister hewitt whenever a
prosperity has drenched with youngblood
i call it a prosperity and i've got a
better name for the man
i'd call it blooded graveyard prosperity
you are i suppose referring to korea sir
as a matter of fact in mail i mention
this now that you raised korea
what if anything it is that
where observing the seventh anniversary
of v_ e_ day and here we are a emerged
in a struggle seven thousand miles from
home
where the treasury listers paramount
lioness almost aggregates a hundred and
nine thousand american casualties of the
present time
but here you've got surplus labour going
into the defense plants of the country
here under neutral security in the
marshall plan and that sort of thing we
are exporting some of the surpluses from
america
that is not adorable prosperity it's got
just a little touch of a holy young
blood upon it
and that's why i call it a piece of
victory
senator dixon here of course uh...
have been very active in the
presidential campaign
and i'm sure that then you're a great
leader and a protest movement against
the administration i'm sure that our
audience would like to have your
prediction alastair how that fight
against the government this year's going
well mister if you are you referring to
the uh...
campaign on the republican side of the
examined
well as the world so well knows i'd
throw my marbles in with bob taft
uh... i'm always heartened by the fact
that as i get around the country they
say he's the best of the republican
party has and then of course the
conviction of a little by saying
but of course is you know
he can't win
well as a matter of fact i manage his
campaign in illinois
and we gave them a little over a nine
hundred thousand votes as a
demonstration that bob tech and we're
well thank you know i'm very much
involved ask for me because i think he
would make a great president
he may not make the greatest president
that you have ever had but he'll be one
of the greatest of america ever had well
thank you very much for being with us
tonight sir
the editorial board for this edition of
the law engine problems call it was
mister william bradford hwy
and mr donald i rogers our distinguished
guests one of the honorable everett
dirksen united state senator from
illinois
do you have a problem of selecting a
gift of great prestige for someone
important to you
well that problem is not happening
solved with launching the world's most i
watch
because of the fine quality of the watch
itself
and because of what the name montagne
stands for
to the whole world logging stands as the
only walked in history
to win the highest of all awards for the
eight times at world's fairs and
international expositions
including ten grand prizes and twenty
eight gold medals
launching the world's most honored watch
stands for the walk to fresh choice in
sports aviation science
and other fields of precise timing
lunging stands for the only watch for
the classified for
at the four great government
observatories washington geneva cupid
ington and attractive
the gift of great prestige for
graduation
an anniversary for any important
occasion is launching the world's most
are not watch
and throughout the world no other name
on a watch means so much
if you made by a normal body and
probably give are launching watch for as
little as seventy one fifty
launching the world's most are not one
prevail product of the laundry in
britain or what company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of doctors at the highest
this is david ross
for your regular post grad night
inviting you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday
at the same time
for the long think one of school
a television journalist of the important
issues of the hour
passed on to have laundry
the world's most bottled water
and reply
distinguished companion
a lot of laundry
old and service
by more than
play december
people on gene written off
one helped
television journal of the implementation
of the house presentation of the laundry
and what's not watch just maker up small
jane the world's most on it a lot
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on its own gene
good evening
this is david rocks
may i introduce ella co-editors for this
edition of the launching promise kal
mister william bradford you we had a
tour of the american mercury and
lieutenant colonel and soulcalibur an
editor of the new york herald tribune
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable fred a season
united state senator from nebraska
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
sends a signal graded your nebraska
newspaperman who say they have to plan
of uh... late senator query
can i say we like
you tell us something about
impressive ended flat situated in your
area
now can you describe for our audience
something about how serious this flood
has been saved
yes i'd be glad to have to do it
this president suri river flooding of
the greatest in the history of man
not only goes to the white mangroves
insofar as the archaeologist compelling
entire history of the indians and anyone
who may have come before them
how many people are lost their homes
over driven from their homes as far as
removed told mom about eighty thousand
people had to be evacuated but managed
to a larger percentage of those homes
and not
and what is the property damage
uh... we believable exceed three hundred
million dollars
now of course to this river has been
rampaging including for many years can
you give us some indication of
and how much loss has been over the
period of the last ten or twelve years
login in actual damages a to
installations of buildings with towns of
public utilities of farm fencing barnes
and that sort of thing
the damage is done about that one in
three quarters billions of dollars
congress has been played in certain
quarters
appropriating enough money for an
adequate tough luck control program do
you think that's a fair criticism
well of course is a member of that
congress colonel even relief
asked me to give you a complete
affirmative
i would say that some of the four has
been congress' yes and determination of
first things first
probably congress' missed a little bit
on what was first
feels like uh... it's a matter of more
money or better players
things matter more money because we have
the poignantly
the fix loan plan which was first uh...
adopted in nineteen hundred and
forty-four sperling adequate support is
taking care of the missouri river basin
and its flood situation is concerned
when we need the money to carry the
flame out you can stop the flow with
paper
challenge would like to know something
about that
picking on plan now is this the plan
thrown out by the army engineers for
controlling the river food is really
bombarded planner
was to do anything
me to authors of that word general paper
the army engineers and players along the
department of agriculture
uh... technically it is today known as
the fixed phone plan beyond amendment
young amendment came about through the
efforts are demanding glad when young
low
carried out the idea of upper one or
shed controllable of the revert
so that you didn't start all of your
efforts on the main spaniel some water
back in other words on the forms and
hillsides leading down to the
tributaries are the main stand there and
that's this is a plan for the
construction by the federal government
of a okay
of a number of dams and roads that's
correct about how many campuses is
engaged in the plan
well all in all of you carried out the
complete plan will be about a hundred
such installations in the military bases
not now remember the missouri basin just
doesn't little playing the river flows
down because actually you've got
of up to six lamb i am united states in
that basin
but there are four major names involved
in that those four bands one completed
would stop a repetition of the flood we
had in nineteen fifty two please
as a surfeit edu
president truman's planned i believe
involving six billion dollars for
national flood control is not part of
the president's plan
uh... yes i'm glad you used the word
party williamsport
course the president's plan the
encompasses a great many things besides
the construction of these main spend and
spend and and the flood control in the
tributaries
and on the phone lines
i'd rather not be in the position of
trying to defend the president's plan of
six million circuit all mine
well i i i wrote and said
and we we we know that uh... we can
spend a great deal of money and we can
get some benefits but now i just how
much money
that do the people of the united states
have to spend to complete the pics on
plan other complete the pics
long-planned again for the
the job of controlling these ravaging
floods on the missouri river
would cost the people of the united
states about a billion three hundred
million dollars
or four hundred
a million dollars less when the floods
along with the cost of the united states
veteran said if needed spreads in the
last ten years it cost the people in the
united states more than it will cost to
build these damn
yes that's right an actual damages out
of those and getting out of those floods
at their cost of the people in in new
york and other people who knew that said
that area
uh... they expensive to us
if you haven't at least alone at least
two ways one maybe moment tangible and
difficult to visualize
we know that whenever you have flood
damage more damage from anything of
tornado which of course you can't
control
at gmail soccer about a twenty percent
lawson income tax collections
now i assume that everybody listening to
this program pays income taxes in this
day and age in america
so you can charge up twenty percent of
his total loss
to the people here in new york state for
instance fair share of the growing at
the more taxes because those people out
there won't make the money to pay them
allen specifically insofar as all of us
are concerned
nineteen fifty two flood on the missouri
river will cost the average family in
united states
at least fifteen dollars and fifty cents
on their grocery bill
because you see them sorry basin is the
bread basket of america
and we know that those losses we
suffered in farm programs
will cause a one percent increase in the
cost of everybody's
food for the ensuing near in other words
every campaign in new york great land a
jacksonville florida
or chicago every family in the united
states will have to pay fifteen dollars
more for food this year because of this
flooded i think that is correct and
that's a very conservative good week and
the fam
shudder
but seem to be getting worse and worse
in your opinion
every really accomplished anything in
flood control up to now
or yes colonel
we can talk all evening about that but
uh... though so far the missouri basin
is concerned
the construction while before pixmania
which was closed last year
till now for those flood waters
that had the band not been there
the flood would have been two feet
higher in omaha council bluffs here in
south dakota the walls
well of course i would just because a
vision of millions and millions of
dollars of damage because
but chances are been impossible the
whole bit blood within the levees which
this which they had all the flood now
and i don't know exactly on that had
been completed now that's that's part of
your picture on prayer and it's one of
the four major hand gesture we're
telling us that because you can't you
had that damn completed
the tribe was not as bad as it would
have been without that that people of
the correct
and reached down that he has now
completed
uh... will reduce the danger of any any
future for that
yes i think everybody who has studied
the river
the army engineers a civilian
authorities even the people who argue
about the pics long-planned
all agree that the fort bans when
completed
withheld the flood waters back to the
extent that instead of having a fun
women who had a state of the river about
two feet less than floodlight all the
way down the river
tumor joins a mississippi designed to
declare four yes one of the issues that
divide our people mostly
if you're on the tennessee valley
authority
i think we americans are divided into
though to those who think t_v_a_
something pretty great and those who do
not
now at is there any enthusiasm in the
misery that it's already p_d_a_ plan
very little sir and what there is is the
engendered primarily by the exciting
department united states government and
by the
uh... bureau of the interior of the
federal government subir
clicking on a national scale
in whose hands worldly flood control of
problems of the future fallen me
army engineers and a national hardy the
order
first that's uh... that's a national
question though so far as the missouri
basin areas concern of the ten states
out there in the midwest and west
if we have our way in the control of
this thing will be in the hands off
representatives of those ten states
drawn from the so-called penn state
compact and from the governor's
conference of those ten states
now you know i i i think for tech damn i
believe gave his no is not i had to
electric damage it
no it is not is just for flood control
answer narrated here that the proposed
damage to be hydro-electric dams
yes uh... some of the more however the
production of hydro-electric power or
the promotion of electrical energy is
not a major part of the big storm plan
it is interjected into the plant only so
far as it is necessary to amortize the
cost of some of these bands
so that the irrigation water drawn from
the bands will not be permitted even
close to the farmers
and short now are people can understand
the in the missouri badly
you're not going to have under that plan
aidid a power development similar to
what we've had in the and the tennessee
valley and then add in the northwest
mall you will have neither the emphasis
on power that you had in the tennessee
valley when you look when you have the
extent of manufacture
and uh... and and met a really remain
primarily agricultural bend and and and
your plan disease and famine in two ada
irrigation and and crop development
irrigation the course of canceling
proper bollam flood control in
navigation on the missouri at least up
to the point of all
now when winds there it will be
pixel unplanned for controlling this
river when will it be completed
according to the president's get you
well according the present schedule on
the basis of the appropriations which of
the made up to first with your
fifty-three
it would be
at least nineteen sixty before these
major brands were completed major
installations were in on the river mall
if we get our way
uh... we will try to bring that up and
certainly found that terminal date by
three years on you know as in other
words now add strength is eight years
uh... to take a test completed here's a
senator from nebraska
but trying to cut down that time
i'm sure that our audience very much
appreciate your views tonight you and
thank you for being with us
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promise coliforms
mister william bradford hwy hand
lieutenant colonel and soul calibur
our distinguished guest was the
honorable quitting seton united state
senator from nebraska
do you have a problem of selecting the
gift of great prestige for someone
important to you
well that problem as most happily solved
with long gene
the world's most honored watch
because of a fine quality of the
launching walks
and because
of what the name
laundry dispensable
to the whole world laundry and stands as
the only watch in history
to win the highest of all awards
thirty-eight times at world's fairs and
international expositions including ten
grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals
launching stands as the water first
choice in sports
science and other fields of precise
timing
and launching stands for the watch
that is one highest observatory accuracy
honors
the gift of great christie's for any
important occasion
is launching
the world's most honored watch
and throughout the world
no other name on a watch
means so much
yet you made by and old all by and
probably give along gene watch
for as little as seventy one fifty
long gene
the world's most honored one
premier product of the laundry with more
what's company
since eighteen sixty six maker of
watches are behind this character
for the long gene promise school
a television journal
of the important issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most armored hua
and
whitmore
distinguished companion
to the world armored laundry
sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading
jewelers
who proudly display this emblem
agency for long gene whitmore watches
times lava launching thomas
television journal of the implementation
of the house
russell you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry look small
watch company
later on
launching the world's most ahmed watch
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world ahmed launching
good evening
this is david rocks
may i introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching promised school
mister william bradford hwy editor of
the american mercury
and mister altman read junior of the new
york herald tribune
our distinguished guests for this
evening
is the honorable henry cabot lodge
junior united state senator from
massachusetts
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
mr lyons
it's a great pleasure for us to and even
i don't know lunging promise closer
audience knows you college says this
thing the senator from massachusetts
and tonight would like to ask you
something about
general eisenhower's tactics when he
returns here
now so can you tell us first
can you tell our audience
uh... what some of general eisenhower's
plans are when you're rags in the united
states
well he plans to her
arrive in washington and then
good abilene kansas where he makes a
speech on me
on the fourth of june on june the
fourteenth speaks in abilene about how
many speeches on their lives do you
think he should and well night you could
tell at this for it
what is this is a great mistake true
make your plans for the end of the
campaign three months ahead you
shouldn't do that
well i understand that is uh...
we heard a rumor that he was going on in
colorado north probably spend a great
deal of june and colorado best-kept
secrets of the whole campaign are not
that the six thousand people and under
and it never got put in the store
sunday lodge but skinning
uh... what subjects do you think general
eisenhower ought to be aware that
hard-hitting subjects and made speeches
that he well might
why do you think and shot the people in
this country would like to know that
they are not play rise yet
well i think people are pretty clear
about eisenhower i think most of them
talk about not being clear comes from
the campaign managers of his opponent
and i think one when not to run the
campaign is to run it sows to please
your photos campaign managers
uh... we had a big victory mentioned is
the other day
uh... have a lot of people voted for
eisenhower in fact he ran a very strong
in the democratic primary
as other staff campaign campaign manager
of the immoral
that we want to get democrats and the
promise of a briseno
well it is much of the republicans only
have twenty one percent of the vote
how are you going to win if you don't
have the democrats the independent legal
about cats and dogs with house i don't
know
now
senators
there has been uh... consider both
thought
and discussion about
said general eisenhower would use in
about his being warned to say it's say
nothing
parties being warned of a forthright
how do you expect him to be forthright
in his answers to questions when he
returns here of course but you can get a
happily tactics
uh... we we've we've got to have a
tactics
in this campaign we feel is the most
popular man which is the best qualified
men is men everybody wants
and also job is to say that that demand
is translated into
let's take uh... i think he's because
he's going to be forthrightly always has
been
you're going to be just as forthright in
dealing with domestic pressures and
political questions that we have been
dealing with military farms persons with
no doubt about that you don't think that
then that uh...
that he is gonna temp to follow a tactic
of saying nothing and what it is pretty
ridiculous
i think that is ours is ridiculous is
the role of the group without
by his opponents lilly was devastated
for middle after the convention
processes improve within a visible in
clothes
he's going to be just as
freed of the property was present at
columbia now i'll point to start all
those things were obviously
places on the face of the all sunday la
jolla delegate because they've been
really she will get him to return it
fabricate them
while sound a lot for example on certain
questions as claire i general eisenhower
stands on the whole subject of socialism
but do you think guidance on that
principle to the particular
he should be a little together things
that are current such as the steel
strike at at at at live com tone
well i don't think you ought to go into
legislation that
was enacted the taft hartley law was
enacted the with mary hogan bill that
banker jones act i don't think you need
to go back
across his opponents would like him to
say how he would have voted if he had
been a senator drill f_-fifteen unit
we want to sell it
anyone exactly wasting his time either
and i can imagine no greater weight of
the public's time than to try to figure
out how he would have voted by the
federal o_j_ has artistic athleticism
respects and i think that i think issues
that involve the future
uh... those of special things but
something else again
this specific issue uh... that tad land
soil
i believe he took a specific position on
that didn't last week they did not
letter that was released in texas are
not sure
well as adlai the list of published
report bashing powers forces in texas
jack porter
had received a letter from last art
which seemed to indicate or they
interpret it
that he had taken uh... the texas and
california position for states rights on
time and so i'll
packed
did you understand that that western
laura dern of democrats are where air
i think there was some other thoughts
within the letter federal jack porter
icing on quite a few thank you wouldn't
you think it would be in the states and
to take it as a that action power has
endorsed the texas position on taxes and
i wouldn't say that i said his letters
etc water
was not go simple it was a brief review
of the
indicate i said there was a other
thoughts in there about oil
care comes back
okay
mary claire his opposition to the
administration's foreign policy in
certain areas
side ministrations policy
kara what is going to study the material
running so he doesn't have to have me to
do that
uh... i know that he's always been
critical of the administration's foreign
policy
thus far back as potsdam he told the
president that we should make no
concessions to the russians to get
through the war games penitent
and that was advice had been followed we
wouldn't have had the mistakes of the
altar of gold would not have been sold
on the river and trying to whatever
savings that have betrayed i know all
there are always going to say
either man well able to make a good one
for themselves
uh... senator let's come back just a
moment to your point about uh...
as perhaps being immoral to attract
democrats into the republicans are
marked or well criminals picnic
my point is that you cannot possibly win
by going absolutely should withdraw hota
uh... you have to attract democrats and
independents right are you concerned sir
about the fact that
a great many new dealers are apparently
supporting general asking how r
william name one
well i don't know
particular facility but i mean we were
at work
well though is that fact is it true that
in in your dealers in massachusetts are
supporting the general
i don't know how much newman and what i
don't know that my democrat well i'd say
allah tension name when mister norman
thomas i believe it is a little uh...
having expressed himself on this show to
the three weeks ago he scheduled for a
few supporters are together for all i
know
we have millions and millions of
supporters and excluding probably
welcome everybody
that supply demand that uh... i'm trying
to make is that
you as a republican leader you're quite
anxious to get through
democrats and even your dealers to vote
for the general if necessary
i think they're trying to drag a little
parliament arithmetic further
every republican motor voter bill would
be forty one percent of the world
well you just cannot win with only one
percent
you've got to augment
when you've got to get democrats are
independent rose can you go
all right
sleeping i think you can say and
sweeping victory in massachusetts new
york ended in other states recently
do you think his chances for winning on
the first batter pretty yet at this
point fifty pdt impossible to tell about
about this time of this far ahead you
character or whether it's the first of
the second of the flu the foreperson
possible toe
do you have uh... and let me ask you
this as his principle campaign manager
or as one of his campaign managers have
you been satisfied with the campaign to
date sir
has it gone along the lines that have
been any surprises for you
wonderful who've been running it and and
and uh...
uh... i don't suppose anybody who's ever
satisfied with what he does i i
uh... don't think any man feels he's
done his best work all the time
i've had some disappointments of course
what are your plans and airline wants
child has nine in
former candidate for re-election to the
united states senate massachusetts
you would not want to be his campaign
manager for example
well miller one of the error i don't
know it
uh... adult hartford
you understand this but i look up to the
congressional request beyond
well now i do you have a very much to do
between now and the convention of the
road
at a time to speculate about what
happens after the congressional idea any
announced opposition in massachusetts as
yet
busy and mister kennedy and it's going
to be a opponent their isabella stewart
he's already announced respected have
any is there any opposition in the
republican primary electorate
you don't expect any i don't know about
it
but i know of the republicans need to
move through this
full of surprises
out of making a difference
now uh...
we would you can't predict forrester
estou there
how many votes uh... general eisenhower
will hailed by june the twenty s
i've never met a production of mywire
for
uh i say that we're ahead now
i say that the uh...
poll reported in the papers are
incomplete
necessarily so because they don't know
the and witness of all the situations
the way i do
uh... salim
holes in the papers are misleading
where do you how many committed
delegates to ukraine for the general i'm
not claiming anything numerically at all
at any time
when you said that the task forces
advanced optometric hair on them and not
done again substantially
well from the program out of the ohio
primary is held
so the judge is going to make some games
but that is something that we can
anticipate on-time content it partially
here i don't think uh... you gotta make
any games
uh... in the in the true sense out to be
done to get his
is hardcore approach that we're all
nominees hair
but he hasn't been again anything
outside of the senate as a as a final
question sir
and speaking as a republican leader
do you think that there will be
and he is really serious hoooo
moons in the republican party as a
result of this coming convention do you
expect to see a united party after the
convention whoever gets the nomination
but i do with the present time
i certainly do and i certainly hope so
i think i've are going to be nominated i
think i have in our appeals to follow it
in the republican party all factions all
groups
he showed his new hampshire
he shall never new jersey and
massachusetts everywhere they had a
chance to express themselves for senator
i'm sure that our audience very much
appreciate your views tonight and thank
you very much for being with us
the editorial board for this edition of
the laundry in front of school was
mister william bradford here we had this
problem re julia
our distinguished guest was the
honorable henry cabot lodge junio united
state senator from massachusetts
here our viewers of the famous mobile
this economy run time by launching as
official watch for the american
automobile association
we'll have a dual cooperate because it's
the type of event that would sure we
approve
and open contest that war where the
results win or lose are made public
power congratulations to mobile gas
and you know that it was uh... in just
under open competition in the laundry in
the game and the fact of the world's
most donald watch it
yesen worlds best competition
the results win or lose all public
danielle laundry and watches nab one
highest honors wherever entered but
don't look and world's fair grand prizes
and twenty-eight gold medal awards
yes and in observateur a accuracy
contest still long-chain watches have
one innumerable honors for accuracy at
all the great national observatories
now if you wish to own just about the
finest watch made anywhere in the world
your choice might well be launching
the world's most honored watch
as a gift for any important occasion or
for yourself
no other name on a watch means so much
as long jeans
the world's most about wat
premier product of old long-chain with
no watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of waters of the highest character
this is david ross speaking for your
regular host frank nice inviting you to
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening
at the same time for the launching
promise school
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most on the block
and whitney
distinguished
companion to the world are not launching
sold and servers from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading
jewelers
will probably a display
agency for launching with no water
anymore
on the all
you
all
plunging watchers that one can welfare
grand prizes twenty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other time
launching the world's most honored
watches made in guaranteed by the
launching what law watch company
in time for the laundry in front of him
television journal of the implementation
of the opt partial you every monday
wednesday and friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on
launching the world's mohammed law
and what
distinguished companions of the world on
its own
good evening
alco editors for this edition of the
laundry in front of school
william bradford hearing editor the
american military
notion warren washington correspondent
of the bottle career experts
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable herbert lemans united
state senator from new york
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
senator leahy arcata school portents of
course no juicer
for your long and distinguished
public service career as governor of new
york
humanitarian service with and i'm now is
senator from new york
and we understand so that your paramount
interest now is an immigration
back what is the question it may have of
immigration and issue at the present
time
wellness usually i think that his
notebook
of great importance today because the
press in immigration laws
go back to nineteen hundred and
thirty-four
and that based on the nineteen hundred
and twenty census
that confusing complicated based on
intolerable concepts
of racism in racial discrimination
they need womanizing liberalizing and
khadafy
there's another important reason why we
have to pick up the matter because the
president recently
a suggestion to the congress
met three at least three hundred
thousand additional persons be admitted
into this country
refugees from communist jerry and said
this is people's
timidly grease the netherlands and
western give me
yet pending
in congress today to bills on
immigration
lundy mccarran walker-viola
and the other
subs to fill the humphrey demanded
centered lehman high understand that you
are not particularly in favor of the
mccarran water bill could you tell us
what so i would like a lot of david
letterman you guessed it because i think
a lot
we can't be a lot of
uses police measures
and texas
racist principles in discrimination into
our laws which are up the republican
to american
ideals
some of the depiction of the make and
what would be allow that
discretion
with regard to the admission of people
is that the talent to the conscience
abroad
and based on his opinion
not on fact and there's no
from that opinion
i believe the bill would slam the door
in future immigration
i believe it would threaten hundreds of
thousands of aliens
uh... now in this country would
deportation
on technical and said under substantial
grounds in five min
five thread of
revocation of citizenship it what the
props and as a ship
thousands literally thousands
without people who have been naturalized
or maybe naturalized in the future
now did you have to go out as an example
is that what i mean
take the question of deportation under
the mud can b l
and in in in this country thirty years
with white american white children
grandchildren
could be deployed it had committed if he
committed a crime however insignificant
twenty five or thirty years ago he could
be suddenly he has been deported
instead back give me is how quickly with
no chance eleven saying his family again
another alien might have lived here
thirty or forty years
way back in the nineteen twenties status
say he might have belonged to an
organization
which you can eat general now clients
abrasive
yet and might have said that connection
with this organization twenty years ago
a more
but under the mat can be helped not only
could he be seized and deported
no matter how old are abiding since then
but no it would have no chance of appeal
the question of the revocation of
citizenship which i think it's uh...
uh... totally evoking
the prosecution of course i'll
constitution courses
at there's no distinction between a
table on a naturalized citizens
the mccann built authorizes
the revocation of naturalization taking
away our citizenship
for acts not serious enough to
constitute the
even up crime the native-born citizens
get a couple of instances on that
a naturalized citizen
refuses testimony before congressional
committee investigating service to that
he could be deprived of citizenship
if this refusal
is within ten years after you'd been
naturalized
and another naturalized citizen
joins the communist front organization
for any purpose or reason
within five years of his naturalization
naturalization and his citizenship good
could be could be taken away from you
and i have answered all at senator lott
on legislation you have an answer to
that in the slate yes i have to be i
want to say that
them again bill would create
a huge number of second-class citizens
constantly under threat
of losing american citizenship
uh... famous newspaper columnists reason
these days
if this pending legislation in the town
one of the uh...
should be enacted
we might as well take the statue of
liberty out of new york oppa
and send it back to a friend who wins
the game
popiel the hopi naman dito
safeguards the politics and possible
civil rights
and lebanese
even parades
it not only revivals
and codifies but also with the risers
and human actions
operation immigration laws
it makes it possible
for an increased number of of witty
immigrants
to come to this country
week will be on your spoke yesterday
the unusual names
come because
such a large number
in way back in nineteen fourteen
nineteen twenty four were assigned
through the northern countries like
england and holland and belgium and
france
and not use
we pull those
and use them
foca for people
anywhere in the work in which they may
come
and that means the admission
not be increased
in the total number of
of immigrants because that will still be
limited to a hundred and fifty thousand
but increases the number that actually
can be increased in will be increased
by about eighty or ninety thousand
five billion to
it is important
we do an obvious
delay emphasis
forms of family unit
and the desirability of really your
reuniting divided families
entirely it would improve relations with
people in europe
not only by a
omitting increased immigration into this
country
but by removing racial unnatural
discrimination
whichever route as being the guy
connects them
against this
among peoples abroad
for senator i'm sure that our audience
very much appreciate your views on
immigration
now tonight and then uses these steel
seizure the presidency chair of the
steel properties and has been a great
deal of criticism
now are you sure generally in sympathy
with the president's action
i think the president had no alternative
but to seize the steel companies
i think
two thirty p happened two things with
that
if it's ever been had been made on the
basis demanded by the steel companies
now the wage an increase of twelve
dollars of time
which in my opinion was entirely and
justifiable
it would have inevitably lead to serious
violent inflation
which would have been eight great trip
to the solvency
and security of this country and
furthermore
if he had to seize the steel mills
it would've made it clear to him and
possibly have as much as five to seven
million tons
of steel
greatly needed commodity which is in
short supply
and would have ended up in that way
uh... threatened
depends
activities articulated
and our national economy and you know i
don't think the president that andy
alternative and then you're not greatly
concerned over the constitutional issue
that's been raised tonight i'm not a
constitutional law and i i i i can't
express any opinion but i believe that
the president
and it's been show and i think by the
history of this country
not only has the right but they do
to do everything he can
to safeguard the security uh...
his of our country
now i think the security of our country
could easily have been threatened by a
steel strike and i think the president
under those circumstances
it the only thing
and they courageous
and right thinking president could have
done
psych seizing the steel mills sender
mastectomy questioning into the
political field for a moment
we having some conventions coming up i
understand you're going to new york
tomorrow at a dinner honoring w
people here are my dad which there will
be some presidential candidates
number one on the political questions do
you have any preference for a candidate
at this time on the democratic ticket
pat and going to the dinner
and then speaker
i have not
i have not express my views
up to the present time with regard to
the candidate on the democratic ticket
or on the republic
but after the dent out going on for this
to be a meeting in a favorite son from
new york is to be a selected is that
right sir s on friday on consulting with
some of the other democratic leaders in
new york
and we will discuss the whole situation
your favorite candidate for the u_s_
senate to uh... for the seats and uh...
held by arriving in lives for the
democratic minority owned tinkered this
one
that has been discussed until
all still i have not discussed his
editorial in my opinion is wide open
what what we have not had not reached
and what is what is your opinion sir as
a final question what is your opinion of
mr erode hammond
i have a
of very
hira dot
abraham
i've known him for a great many years
and in my opinion there is no more
patriotic
no more able man in this country of ours
of
enable habbo thank you very much for
being with us
the editorial board for this edition of
the laundry room promised go for it
william bridget healy added to the
american migraine
motion warren washington correspondent
for the bottle career express
our distinguished guests what they are
moderately mum
united state senator from new york
the big news in the world of sports is
the opening of the major league baseball
team
here at school year
form part of the both american and
national reporting
we would probably want to fix it
priming ballgame throughout the day
winding up of the world series
front lawn
portland comprehensive
including
the conference board of the american
automobile association
the american powerboat association
for national aeronautic association
and for nineteen fifty two have been
united states olympic committee
at selected laundry watches for climbing
all events for the selection of the
united states olympic team
wisely so
well the answer is found in the greater
accuracy which has been built into every
launching watch
accuracy as an established fact
proven year after year
in the competitive
accuracy trials
conducted by the great government
observatory
that is right throughout the world
northern name on the water
the world's most armored one
friendly our product of the long
being written or what company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of waters of the highest there
this is david ross
speaking for your regular holes
inviting you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
for the long team chronicle
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of laundry
the world's most arnold what
whitmore
distinguished companion
for the world armored laundry
sold in service
by more than four thousand meeting to
order
probably the slavery emblem
agency belong to you with norwalk